le chef de l'état français en direct sur
un média social destiné aux jeunes un
long entretien avec emmanuel macron
réalisé par un journaliste frappé par un
policier au cours des récentes
manifestations violences policières
colonisation algérienne loi sur les
séparatistes ou écologie des questions
posées avec la participation des
internautes
un grand entretien avec le chef de
l'état qui intervient en pleine
polémique sur la loi dite de sécurité
globale les syndicats de journalistes
ont été reçus ce matin par leur ministre
de tutelle
ils réclament toujours la suppression
des articles controversés mais aussi le
retrait du nouveau schéma de maintien de
l'ordre la france également mise en
cause par l'onu sur l'article 24 qui est
en passe d'être réécrit par le
gouvernement
l'ancien président ivoirien pourrait
bien montrer bientôt au pays toujours en
liberté conditionnelle en belgique
laurent gbagbo a obtenu deux passeports
et due forme poursuivi pour crimes
contre l'humanité il a été acquitté en
première instance par la cour pénale
internationale
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir emmanuel macron
qui a répondu aux préoccupations des
jeunes en direct sur le média en ligne
brut
le chef de l'état qui a été interviewé
pendant plus de deux heures par le
journaliste rémy buzine qui lui-même a
été malmené par la police au cours d'une
manifestation la semaine dernière et il
a été donc question des violences
policières de l'identité des jeunes
issus de l'immigration ou bien de leur
difficulté à cause de la crise sanitaire
un entretien en longueur avec les
questions des jeunes sur les réseaux
sociaux
écoutez emmanuel macron je le dis entre
guillemets ya le citoyen victime et le
policier violent il ya de la violence
dans notre solution en terme de violence
ya de la violence dans notre société il
y à des policiers violents il nomma est
donc là dessus il faut prévenir formé
alors et surtout sanctionner les
policiers et policières les gendarmes il
s'engage pour servir ils sont pas dans
un camp il protège l'ordre républicain
c'est à dire ce qu'ils font ils le font
au nom de la loi qui a été votée par
celles et ceux qui nous représentent
ils sont pas dans un camp ils sont pas
dans la vengeance est par contre l'autre
une interview qui a donné lieu à
beaucoup de commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux regarder à macron créé un numéro
vert de plus polis justice et pis tout
ça c'est réglé c'est pas un gouvernement
c'est une plateforme téléphonique
oui mais le numéro et vers le climat
aussi est sauvé par les arabes
c'est une chance pour la france c'est ce
que macron refuse de voir c'est que la
langue va au delà de la diversité
linguistique elle constitue ici un gage
d'enfermement communautaire sur brut
macron découvre l'existence des
violences policières qui niait depuis
trois ans sa réponse
retirez la sécurité globale réformer
l'igpn revoir la formation et la
doctrine d'emploi de la police
mais non bien sûr un numéro vert contre
les discriminations
emmanuel macron dit tout et son
contraire il faut renforcer l'identité
française mais aussi changer les
programmes d'histoire se précipiter dans
un vaccin incertain tout en avouant que
celui ci changera d'ici avril
les français ont besoin d'une vision
claire avec ses plateformes délatrice
macron instaure un régime de délation
alors que pour les plaintes
il y a le procureur si j'étais policier
je me sentirais bien seul avec macron
comme président
dans et voyez à présent l'analyse de cet
entretien avec notre éditorialiste
alexis poulain c'est un exercice de
communication politique
davantage qu'une interview on aimerait
voir emmanuel macron en conférence de
presse devant plusieurs journalistes
répondre à des questions délicates là il
rêve à des questions de journalistes
dont rémy buisine qui a subi des
violences policières
place de la république thomas snégaroff
et d'autres qui lui pose quelques
questions et emmanuel macron qui déroule
finalement un argumentaire pour séduire
les jeunes pour expliquer que ce n'est
pas sa faute qu'il a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait qu'on n'est pas en hongrie né en
turquie sans doute que ce passage là va
faire plaisir à erdogan et à viktor
orban et qu' il n'est pas dans cette
dérive autoritaire que la presse
étrangère veut bien lui prêter
balayant ça d'un revers de la main et
disant même que les journalistes
racontent beaucoup de bêtises donc on
est quasiment au même niveau que les
fake news de donald trump quand il
s'adresse aux autres médias et mal
macron ne se remet pas en cause dans sa
pratique du pouvoir
il a du mal à répondre sur les violences
policières
emmanuel macron qui s'exprime en tout
cas de plus en plus sur des médias très
prisé par les jeunes après tik tok il a
donc choisi brut pour le président il ya
évidemment l'enjeu de l'élection
présidentielle même si le chef de l'état
n'a pas exclu aujourd'hui de ne pas se
présenter en cas de difficultés en 2022
estelle farges il avait pourtant dit que
les journalistes ne l'intéressait pas
ses mots du président de la république
emmanuel macron remonte à 2010 est de la
quasi-disparition de la parole
présidentielle dans les médias au début
du quinquennat à cette interview en
direct pour répondre aux questions des
internautes sur le média en ligne brut
trois ans se sont écoulés aujourd'hui
c'est à la jeunesse qu emmanuel macron
entrant est dressé avec un exercice
médiatique sur mesure le but c'est
d'avoir un échange direct avec la
jeunesse de répondre à des questions qui
sont posées à des inquiétudes a des
doutes qui sont formulées la jeunesse
doute du fait de la période qu'on vit
aujourd'hui pas uniquement le
coronavirus il faut les rassurer il faut
échanger avec eux il faut entendre ce
qu'ils ont à dire et il faut y répondre
c'est la quatrième une interview que le
chef de l'état accordé
dia après trois fois en 2010 huit années
de vives contestations des gilet jaune
face au journaliste rémy with in qui
relaye notamment les questions des
internautes
emmanuel macron aborde de nombreux
sujets tels que l'environnement la
laïcité
sans oublier le coc vite 19 et les
violences policières du véritable
marketing politique
une stratégie qui s'explique notamment
par l'absence de poids lourds de la
politique dans l'entourage du chef de
l'état
c'est en tout cas ce qu'estime cette
enseignante en communication politique à
l'université paris xiii chez le confrère
de france info faute de figure très
marquée politiquement dans son entourage
emmanuel macron est obligé de s'adapter
et de s'adresser directement à ses
cibles électorales
grâce à des canaux spécialisés en
parlant à brut
emmanuel macron dit aux jeunes et au
gilet jaune qui suivent ce média vous
méritez ma considération
au delà de ce qu'il pourra dire vendredi
le simple fait que cette interview
existe est un message en soi car la
jeunesse est un enjeu de taille pour
emmanuel macron avec les seniors elles
représentent le socle de son électorat
notamment chez les 18 24 ans c'est en
tout cas ce que révèle le baromètre ifop
fiducial du mois d'octobre
mais c'est un soutien au fragile aussi
selon un autre sondage ifop pour la
tribune cette fois 53% des 18-30 ans se
sont révoltés ou résignés et 22 % se
disent confiants ou enthousiaste pas
étonnant donc emmanuel macron
choisissent brut fondée par guillaume
lacroix et renaud le van kim ancien de
canal+ ce média est entre autres la
propriété de xavier niel et de françois
henri pinault et compte parmi ses
clients france télévisions il est né en
2016 a pour coeur de cible les 18 34 ans
et compte plus de 20 milliards de vues
en 2020 dans son pays différents si
l'audience est au rendez vous les faits
de cette opération séduction lui auprès
des jeunes ne le sera peut être pas
forcément un grand entretien avec le
chef de l'état qui intervient en pleine
polémique sur la loi dite de sécurité
globale
les syndicats de journalistes ont été
reçus ce matin par leur ministre de
tutelle
ils réclament toujours la suppression
des articles ou controversés mais aussi
le retrait du nouveau schéma de maintien
de l'ordre
une nouvelle manifestation est prévue
demain partout en france après les
heurts de la semaine dernière le chef de
l'état s'est exprimé sur le média
tout à leur écoute et et ce sera le cas
aussi de pouvoir nous retrouver demain
puisque une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre l'article 24 de la
loi sécurité globale s'élancera dans les
rues paris on la suivra bien évidemment
comme ne soyez pas violents
traquer toutes celles et ceux qui seront
violents dont fera juste de travail de
journaliste ou si elle table bien sûr et
je pense que là dans la période on a
surtout besoin de se mobiliser pour
construire et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct tout de suite avec emmanuel
vire secrétaire national du snj cgt et
membre de la coordination nationale
hashtags top loi sécurité globale
bonsoir emmanuel bierre merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
vous avez été reçu par roselyne bachelot
ce matin avez vous le sentiment d'avoir
été entendu pas du tout et quand
j'entends le président encore moins ce
soir mais je voudrais juste réagir sur
la séquence où notre confrère aurait me
busy n'annonce les manifestations de
demain par demain c'est plus de 100
manifestations et rassemblements qui ont
lieu dans toutes les villes de france
contre la loi sécurité globale mais le
symbole est quand même très très fort
prévisible c'est le journaliste qui à
chaque manifestation toutes les semaines
est empêchée de travailler par les
forces de l'ordre
et même quand il ne travaille pas il est
entravée et là que le président dise
fait attention à la la pas de violence
mais mais c'est c'est irréaliste les
propos du président sont virales et je
les ai découverts avec vous là parce que
j'avais pas pu voir toute la séquence
est alors encore plus après avoir été
reçus ce matin par la ministre de la
culture qui était je rappelle une simple
reprise de contact puisque la
coordination nationale et les syndicats
de journalistes avaient refusé d'être
reçus la semaine dernière par mathieu
castex premier ministre puisque le
préfet l'allemand de la préfecture de
police de paris avait interdit notre
manifestation la grande marche des
libertés qui a remporté rencontré un
succès considérable la semaine dernière
et que nous avions dû obtenir en justice
au tribunal administratif de paris qui
avait suspendu l'arrêté d'interdiction
de la manif du préfet l'allemand alors
il y aura bien une manifestation demain
vous dénoncez d'ailleurs je cite la haye
la cacophonie qui règne au sein du
gouvernement et de la majorité
parlementaire après l'année
surtout de la réécriture intégrale de
l'article 24 un commentaire peut tout à
fait y a rien de neuf et et ce matin
l'entretien avec madame bachelot et dans
les propos du président en fait tout le
monde le sait maintenant de toute façon
l'avenir de la proposition de loi est au
sénat elle a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale
donc maintenant nous en tant que
coordination nationale contre cette
proposition de loi évidemment nous nous
adressons déjà aux sénateurs mais ce
matin il n'y avait rien de nouveau chez
madame bachelot même la commission
proposée par le gouvernement pour au
début réécrire l'article
on a vu que comme c'était
anticonstitutionnel c'est plus pour
réécrire l'article mais une commission
je sais pas pour discuter pour voir ce
qui va pas le président qui était
présent pressenti pour présider cette
commission le président de la cncdh
on a appris ce matin qu'en fait il ne
pouvait même pas présider cette
commission car il faudrait qu'il
démissionne de son mandat de président
du lait du cncdh donc qu'on aurait une
commission sans président pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de lettre de mission il n'y
a pas de composition de cette commission
non on est dans le plu en amateurisme le
plus total
on comprend mal d'ailleurs parce que
même l'onu on l'a vu aujourd'hui
critique cet article 24
on comprend pas pourquoi le gouvernement
ne veut pas lâcher du lest sur cette
question est ce que c'est une question
de crédibilité notamment pour gérald
darmanin qui est qui a poussé cet
article 24 mois je veux pas rentrer dans
ce débat là où est ce que c'est une
stratégie du politique du président pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 ce
que je sais pas c'est que moi j'ai
vraiment mal au coeur j'ai mal à mon
pays de voir des experts de l'onu de
voir la défenseure des droits devoirs
tous à mettre m tellement à mal l'image
de la france quoi et je vois le
président à brut comme ça balayés sadin
cela d'un revers de main mais ces essais
c'est vraiment mais ils comprennent
toujours pas et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment demain il y ait beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de citoyens dans
l'ensemble des rassemblements organisés
partout en france donc temps que cet
article 24 et les articles 21 et 22 ans
également
ne sont pas retirés vous continuerez de
manifester bien sûr et aussi la
réécriture du schéma national de
maintien d'abord parce que vous avez
compris de par les annonces du président
que là dessus il ya rien de nouveau
en fait on nous créer un numéro vert on
va faire quoi on va signer à l'ailé on
va signer à laisser les violences
policières
mais de toute façon les violences
policières ne sont pas traitées quant à
la réforme de l'igpn elle est toujours à
l'ordre du jour le président nous dit
juste au bas y aura plus de transparence
dans le suivi des dossiers
mais les dossiers c'est par exemple 200
plaintes de journalistes qui n'ont pas
été traités par l'igpn
ou alors dont on n'a aucune nouvelle un
certain journaliste parle d'un droit à
la censure sur des reportages et des
documentaires
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
préciser ses propos oui tout à fait
c'est juste ministère de l'intérieur qui
demande à voir des images de production
avant qu'elles puissent être diffusées
c'est complètement hallucinant et on
aime ça et ça a été le cas sur certains
portages lesquels pas sûr je ne venais
pas de reportage en inde mais on demande
à signer dès à ce que la préfecture
puissent voir les reportages avant qu'il
soit diffusé
ou alors la semaine dernière pendant la
manifestation plusieurs journalistes ont
reçu des messages de la sûreté nationale
qui puisse me voir les vidéos tournées
par ses journalistes afin de mettre la
lumière sur les violences qui ont lieu
pendant les manifestations
oui effectivement la sécurité a demandé
aussi ces images à notre chaîne
près de 90 policiers blessés la semaine
dernière qu est ce que ça vous inspire
est ce que le service gmail qui est un
service d'ordre aussi qui est en place
demain de votre côté vous allez tenter
de
de contrôle est peut-être un peu mieux
cette situation amène où on est tous
temps et d'ailleurs il faudra interroger
des services de la préfecture mais
demain on sera la quatrième mobilisation
nationale de la coordination la
préfecture reconnaît que nous nous
mettons tout en place pour que la
sécurité soit respectée demain il y aura
plus de 100 personnes sur le service
d'ordre de la manifestation parisienne
par exemple
donc ça et nous ce n'est pas à nous de
gérer le maintien de l'ordre
le maintien de nos nounous manifestants
il n'y a pas de souci c'est la stratégie
du maintien de l'ordre qui doit être
discuté et il suffit de voir avec les
autres pays européens en belgique en
italie au royaume uni en allemagne ce
n'est pas la même stratégie de maintien
de l'ordre
et donc il faut que vraiment il ya une
réflexion et le président l'acceptent
toujours pas ce soir il est toujours
droit dans ses bottes et nous dit à
l'attention mais tout ça et caricatures
au vous en faites trop mais non non
l'image de la france est profondément
dégradé tout le monde le dit maintenant
il faut retirer cette proposition de loi
et revoir intégralement le nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre
une réaction très court s'il vous plaît
sur l'audition de gérald darmanin cette
semaine devant l'assemblée nationale
il est resté droit dans ses bottes pour
un ministre de l'intérieur vous en avez
pensé quoi beaucoup d'eux pour tout vous
dire j'étais j'étais même peiné parce
que je moi j'ai les réactions des
syndicats européens de journalistes moi
j'ai les réactions des confrères qui ne
comprennent pas la situation du maintien
de l'ordre en france donc c'est je sais
pas comment comment il faut faire pour
leur expliquer qu'on a besoin de
dialogue
on a besoin de comprendre oui la société
violente dans son ensemble dans tous les
pays européens
tout cela est géré il ya du dialogue on
essaie de comprendre comment les
policiers travaillent on essaie de
comprendre comment les journalistes
travaillent le problème et ça c'est la
seule chose
la seule chose que madame bachelot
ministre de la culture a reconnu en nous
recevant ce matin c'est que comme elle
l'a dit le lien de confiance est rompu
le lien de confiance est rompue à la
fois entre les journalistes et les
pouvoirs publics et les forces de langue
mais aussi heureusement beaucoup
entre les citoyens et les forces de
l'ordre et c'est ce lien qu'il faut
rétablir
c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état
également merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
d'avoir est plus viable casting il a
qu'une chose à faire si vous savez c'est
retirer la proposition de loi sécurité
globale
hélas le l'apaisement sera généralisé
message entendu merci et vire d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur rt
france un article 24 controversé on l'a
dit au delà des frontières de la france
après les critiques de nombreuses ong et
de la commission européenne c'est l'onu
qui a rappelé la france à l'ordre tone
abonnés
la proposition de loi dite de sécurité
globale a provoqué de vives réactions en
france parmi les dispositifs les plus
décriées le désormais célèbre article 24
imaginé pour protéger l'intégrité des
forces de l'ordre mais dénoncé par
beaucoup comme portant atteinte à la
liberté d'informer à la suite de
plusieurs jours de débats et de
contestation dans la rue
le chef de file de la majorité
présidentielle a annoncé lundi sa
réécriture
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui le
choix légistique que nous avons fait à
laisser s'installer un trouble si ce
n'est même la conviction parmi la
population que le droit d'informer que
le droit à l'information que l'exercice
même du contrôle légitimes des actions
de police étaient menacés l' équilibre
que nous avons recherché sur cet article
24 n'a pas été unanimement perçue
contact insuffisant pour calmer les
opposants au texte qui souhaitent son
retrait pur et simple
c'est également la tonalité du côté de
plusieurs experts indépendants auprès de
l'onu qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé la
simple réécriture de l'article 24 ne
résoudra pas ses défauts et cette
disposition n'est certainement pas la
seule dans la proposition de loi qui
porte atteinte aux droits de l'homme
si le débat public s'est focalisé sur
cet article 24 la proposition de loi
prévoit d'autres dispositifs également
mise à l'index par ce même rapport
l'article 22 autorisant l'utilisation de
drones de surveillance au nom de la
sécurité et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme permettrait une surveillance
étendue
en particulier des manifestants cela
aura de graves implications pour le
droit à la vie privée la liberté de
réunion pacifique et la liberté
d'expression dans le pays des
préoccupations exprimées par un collège
d'experts indépendants qui travaillent
donc auprès du conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu
il y a plusieurs jours déjà la
commission européenne avait fait part de
ses réserves concernant cette loi de
sécurité globale inquiétude exprimée
aussi par des ong par la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
et c'est dans ce contexte avec un sens
du timing qui interroge que le compte
twitter de la france à l'onu a publié
cette allocution d' emmanuel macron les
circonstances exceptionnelles engendrés
par la pandémie menace par ailleurs dans
de nombreux pays
l'acquis de plus de 70 ans de combat
international en faveur des droits de
l'homme
la pandémie ne doit pas servir de
prétexte aux restrictions de l'espace de
la société civile recul de l'état de
droit aux atteintes à la liberté
d'expression à la détention arbitraires
d'opposants
pas sûr que le message soit bien reçu au
moment même où la france est pointée du
doigt par les instances internationales
cela avait d'ailleurs déjà été le cas
l'an passé lorsque la haut commissaire
aux droits de l'homme de l'onu avait
demandé des comptes au sujet des
violences policières lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune et en
dépit des récusations du porte parole du
gouvernement
voici une énième illustration de ses
inquiétudes à l'étranger
cette une du dernier numéro de courrier
international
le président de la république qui est
présenté sous un aspect autoritaire avec
cette légende la presse étrangère
s'inquiète du virage sécuritaire pris
par emmanuel macron et près de deux mois
après l'attentât contre un professeur
d'histoire à conflans sainte honorine
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale a publié hier soir le rapport
administratif sur les jours qui ont
précédé la mort de samuel pâtit il en
ressort que l'institution a fait preuve
le site de réactivité
l'inspection générale qui préconisent
également 12 mesures de prévention à la
vie
avec surtout la mise en place d'un
protocole pour détecter les signaux
faibles de radicalisation et une
meilleure surveillance des réseaux
sociaux
regardez lui et gaal en jeu que revêtent
aujourd'hui la présence sur les réseaux
sociaux de contenus relatifs au milieu
scolaire il apparaît nécessaire de
mettre en place ou de faire monter en
puissance des cellules de veille des
réseaux sociaux en mesure d'accomplir
cette mission avec la meilleure
efficacité possible
et voyez à présent la réaction à ce
rapport de l'éducation nationale de
jacqueline eustache brinio à l'essai
sénatrice les républicains du val d'oise
le problème c'est que on a souci c'est
que l'éducation nationale protège
l'intérieur ça a toujours fonctionné
comme ça c'est à dire que bas tout ce
qui se passe à bâtiment on rentre dans
le collège bah on protège cette
institution sauf que dès qu'on franchit
la grille de l'école et ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur
jusqu'à présent ça concerne aimant les
choses peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il va
falloir se poser la question c'est que
en dehors du temps scolaire et sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur l'espace public
aussi un aux abords des collèges aux
abords des lycées aux abords des écoles
primaires il se passe des choses est que
les enfants qui sont à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur
ce sont les mêmes enfants il va falloir
que chacun trouve les moyens de
surveiller ce qui se passe aussi à
l'extérieur du collège et sur les
réseaux sociaux
on sait très bien que des professeurs
parfois craques parce que ils sont
humiliés sur les réseaux sociaux la
réalité là ils sont attaqués ils sont
menacés
et bien c'est aussi un travail qui doit
être fait au niveau l'éducation
nationale et qu'un enseignant qui est
maltraité qui est menacée sur les
réseaux sociaux
même si c'est à 9 heures du soir eh bien
on doit protéger l'institution de la dû
se donner des moyens alors c'est un vrai
danger ses réseaux sociaux c'est un vrai
danger
vraiment
en europe le plan de relance toujours
suspendu à la menace de veto de la
hongrie avec la pologne elle continue de
rejeter le mécanisme qui conditionne le
versement de ces fonds au respect de
l'état de droit si l'union européenne
voit l'ensemble de son budget à venir
menacer
elle pourrait cependant lâché du lest ou
les conseils de l'allemagne florian
lambert le 21 juillet 2020 les 27 états
membres de l'union européenne présente
le plan de relance de 750 milliards
d'euros
après le début de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
rapidement les 27 se divise sur la mise
en place d'un mécanisme qui permettrait
de lier le versement des fonds européens
au respect de l'état de droit et de la
séparation des pouvoirs
après que la hongrie et la pologne
rejoint mardi par les slovènes ont mis
leur veto à l'adoption du plan de
relance de l'union européenne face à la
crise du coc vite 19
le parlement européen s'est montré
inflexible
écartant toute renégociation les
dirigeants du parlement européen
regrette profondément ce blocage et
réaffirme que les accords conclus ne
peuvent en aucun cas être rouvert la
hongrie et la pologne s'oppose fermement
aux mécanismes qui permettraient de les
priver de fonds européens en cas de
violation de l'état de droit
toutefois la pologne a fait ce jeudi un
premier pas vers bruxelles
on peut trouver un compromis même sans
rouvrir la discussion
mais le premier ministre hongrois viktor
orban a éteint ce vendredi les espoirs
européens de compromis rapide au
lendemain d'un premier fléchissement
polonais et a rappelé son allié à leur
promesse de front commun les polonais se
sont également engagés au veto nos pays
ont signé une déclaration affirmant que
la hongrie et la pologne se soutiendront
mutuellement
aucun des deux ne doit accepter une
proposition irrecevable pour l'autre
face à budapest et varsovie
les autres membres de l'union européenne
font bloc
[Musique]
mardi le premier ministre polonais doit
s'entretenir avec le président du
conseil européen charles michel et avec
d'autres chefs de gouvernement à ce
sujet et l'ancien président ivoirien
pourrait bien rentrer au pays à bientôt
toujours en liberté conditionnelle en
belgique laurent gbagbo a obtenu deux
passeports en bonne et due forme un
passeport ordinaire et un passeport
diplomatique ou suivi pour crimes contre
l'humanité il a été acquitté en première
instance par la cour pénale
internationale
voyez ce qu'on dit à la féuo qui lie les
directeurs de l'intelligent d'abidjan
longuement ivoirien a estimé que c'était
le moment par rapport à la procédure qui
était en cours et qui est toujours un
coût encore peut-être son père français
que c'est assez tôt mais l'essentiel
c'est que cela se soit créé maintenant
les discussions sont confiés à qui est
chargée d'un train comptes avec le
gouvernement sous étudier les modalités
de ce retour parce que ces chefs d'état
ou n'avaient vu que l'ambassadeur est un
représentant du gouvernement ivoiriens
se sont déplacés pour lui et m
le passeport cela signifie que il est
traité comme un ancien chef de l'état et
à ce type là ce sont arrivés doivent se
relancer des discussions même s'il
estimait que son parce qu'on ne devait
pas faire l'objet de discussions des
tractations
maintenant c'est pas un simple citoyen
qui retourna en côte d'ivoire c'est un
ancien chef de l'état et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité sur
notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous pour le débat
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus haut